it's becoming more and more obvious that
the West is completely duded in the meme
that it's propagated through the culture
which is now spread across the world
which is that you as an individual
through capitalism through acre money
through saying all ethics I care
not at all about morality or apparent
other or other nations but instead I
will just extract whatever the I
want for this sense of lack and
unworthiness inside and I will create
whatever unethical business practices I
will create whatever manipulations in
the real estate
economies I will perversely shove
Pharmaceuticals down people's throats I
will fund military industrial complexes
and be a shareholder of those and get
dividend from
that I will do I will stomp on top of
people's shoulders I will climb up every
single ladder imaginable and just say
you to every single peasant low
life below
me because what I want is this
insatiable appetite to be fulfilled of
all these material possessions of all
this clout and fame I want all of the
women the men
to want me because I'm the highest on
the hierarchy and I'm the one that needs
to be looked up to as most
valuable and there's the rat race
there's the rat race the whole
cycle is right there the whole thing's
right there where are you going where
are you going where are you going circle
circle circle circle circle where are
you going okay next course next
experience next travel next date next
attainment next thing knowledge next
book whatever it is next thing that I'm
going to get that's going to make me
feel whole that's the Trap that's the
Trap circle circle circle circle circle
it'll never end the the amount of
objects that you can objectify that will
try to get you wholeness will never
end and it's the wholeness that already
is and so that's the question where are
you going it's just a rat race it's just
a rat race there's nowhere to go it's
already wholeness you're already nobody
you're already wholeness you're already
everybody you're already the universal
you're already whole you're already free
there's nowhere to
go nothing that you can possibly attain
can be added on to you because you
you're already
infinite